previously on TV sin you know it's it's
not exactly party to Jan well I've never
really been very good at all of that
[Music]
nobody's saying our neighborhoods a
Garden of Eden
shameless use of opening narration Fiona
my rock huge help Wow are we really
about to use narration to introduce us
to all the main characters even prestige
cable shows can't resist suckling from
the sweet sweet teat of easy exposition
those how to disembowel an enemy will
the roll of Dimes an old gym sock noted
always dragging home some poor stray he
found taking him up to his room casual
implied animal torturers casual
I'm no biologist but he looks a little
bit like my first sponsor he and the ex
were close infidelity jokes keV and
Veronica fantastic neighbors and now
we're moving this macy's narration in
parade onto the neighbors the neighbors
that someone accidentally dub over a
little bill reading the call sheet for
casting into the final show for to
destroy some asses gratuitous milk water
i totally get the humor here but how
practical is this he'll just make him
put his shirt on properly when he gets
to school and he'll still have the
mcdonald stain show me tell show him the
birthmark on his back it looks like
latvia i know public schools ignore a
lot but bringing your baby brother to
class is almost assuredly a no-no when
you tap that ass once if i double bagged
it project girls don't afford grossed
[ __ ] weary aside and the fact that
they would have no clue where fiona
lives if you're telling me there's a
young man alive who would think twice
about emmy rossum then i'm sitting this
out of that person also amazing she can
hear this [ __ ] low whisper insult
when I can't even shout my nachos with
mmm seasoning combo without being asked
twice rest unless acted upon by an
external force how is he surprised by
this there are many things in which
teenage boys are completely clueless
both the girl next to you ducking under
the table to give you a physics lesson
and growing 14 is not one of them yeah
this isn't charity I okay
paid for to drive I know science just
turns me on I'm sending myself for not
being a science tutor in high school
wait a minute I mean Rossum Justin
Chatwin if this turns out to be a
Dragonball Evolution sequel I'm going to
change this TV shows title to shame
holds their purse like this when they
are dancing I was going to sin this
careless handbag re even before I knew
it was going to be part of the force
meet cute that's about to happen can we
just put pockets in women's clothing
already so they don't have to worry
about this nonsense also is personal
and clubs a thing I'm not saying it's
not but this seems like an insanely
stupid idea considering you usually have
to get through a crowded dance floor and
at least two steroid monsters named
something like Ned or Burt was this van
parked out here until the guy came out
with a purse what are the chances the
door guy didn't make him move this whole
operation seems very ridiculous and
unprofitable got a Hummer today
what's lawn sex with pets bestiality
jokes I get it's Emmy Rossum and all but
now that's just a waste of perfectly
good after sex hot dogs let her set the
food down first you animal cop walk
episode takes almost 20 minutes to
properly William H may see a pen mr.
beer keep his disability day okay I get
that the whole point of the show is that
this family has a different moral
compass so they can survive it all but
could we at least just have one person
in this thing that I could root for and
still look myself in the mirror in the
morning no no you're gonna like it
what am i what am I even gonna say
alright yep he's taking his younger
sibling over the same girl in the hopes
of getting in some action and seeing if
he's actually gay like Tommy Boy said
brothers don't shake hands brothers got
to get a blowy from the same horned up
science student for sexual identity
reasons karen is thrilled with you she
got an e just gonna go ahead and remove
one sin because it's Joan Cusack
I mean lip could have just picked up the
Apple so Bill Murray's brother didn't
have to but shows got a show or in this
case blow I guess you know you think
we'd have been proved the falling
through the air effect since the famed
Gruber drop of 88 but apparently you
think wrong no no always elevate
extremities but it was elevated in fact
you took over and elevated it exactly
the same amount it was elevated before
also this is like a sprained ankle it
works why is everyone acting like he's
about to bleed out on acts all rich I
hereby adjust the show could use just
about 37 percent more shame is it just
me or does that food stamp signs seem a
bit defensive food stamps okay settle
down sign I promise no one is judging
you is this show good you have Fiona I
mean technically he said all this at the
beginning of the show with his mind is
it really Frank's fault at Fiona can't
read minds
someone attended the chick-fil-a school
of your welcoming things what was I
wearing first time he saw me if that
wasn't all life black top with gold trim
black shiny jeans thin shoes nice straps
you know I'm sure he remembers some of
the details of the night he first saw
her but I know every last detail I can
tell you in great detail when I first
fell in love with him you're awesome but
I don't remember a damn thing about what
she was wearing oh wait now I do
you're watching her was a lot
better-lookin to me so City belongs in
Jenna's when I'm sick of them
Steve dicks trashy field his friends is
the gateway into her pants she's where
Fiona you're nothing like anyone I've
ever met you make me want to enjoy my
life again yeah yeah yeah she completes
you makes you want to be a better man
blah blah blah can we just remember this
is a dude who stalked you for a couple
of weeks before spending just a few
moments in person with you and then
bought you a brand new household
appliance before professing his undying
well I'm just saying there's more red
flags here than in a communist gift shop
let me guess person can't find who
they're looking for until the vehicle
passes and they're standing on the other
side of it cliche so I lose respect for
guys like Steve because people unlike
Steve I'm going with all the respect is
lost after one starts speaking in the
third person somehow more socially
acceptable than asking myself for
instance why do the men I always date
treat me like whoa slow down show was
partly just trying to squeeze a full
rom-com
plot into the a story of an hour-long TV
episode literally 15 seconds ago these
two were making out and we're already to
the challenging the relationship stage
this is TV man no reason to go full
Reiner on the first day if I've learned
anything from this show and Ferris
Bueller's Day Off it's do never trust
valets in Chicago I know we're supposed
to be all aghast at the fact that
shocker this character is also a dirtbag
degenerate but I can't get past the fact
that somehow he just happened to time
this switcheroo at the exact second
someone pulled up in a fancy car he must
be joking
like you give him so now we can add
pedophiles to the fun list of characters
this show has to offer it's a nice
reveal at all and I know they were gonna
hurry to hide their kwik-e-mart quickie
but it's not like they were getting
dressed in the dark and one of those
shoes is a freakin velcro high-top how
do you not notice you're putting on the
wrong shoe he's married with kids whilst
did he buy you in this is the issue not
that he's an adult hey [ __ ] cheats on
white fundamentalist wife with gutless
gay boy I'm pretty sure lip is just
achieved maximum hist says more about
White Sox fans and us with the rest of
it
nope he found one more because that's
definitely sexist what's the one thing
no we need one word one thing
sterilization continuity fun I'll have
to check with Alanis for confirmation
but I'm pretty sure cutting from a shot
where Frank's left arm is raised from
behind to one in the front where it
isn't well he is actually repeating the
word continuity might be the ironic
estate to ever ironic you dad made me
following up gave me a condom I get
that's supposed to shock me but really
just makes me wonder how a man with this
many kids knows what a condom is I name
a single time I've let you down
pretty sure all the homophobic vines lip
is giving off count for at least a dozen
Norman Rockwell eat your heart out
Shan Shan cuz every single one of them
reminds me of me Karl
I don't really know that much about
[Music]
bring out the [ __ ] you know for the
earth what you all she pregnant I love
you and I'm sick I'll talk to you
outside seeds I'm getting correct
fertile surgery tomorrow and you can't
piss on hospitality people like you or
just wait you used to get in your own
way
what do you mean you people what do you
mean you people huh